[Music]
everybody bleh here what's going on as
you may or may not know here at Team
Coco our favorite holiday is Halloween
Halloween is rapidly approaching so we
thought to celebrate we would have a
contest that's right
a conan eyes your costume contest here's
how it works first of all you get
dressed up in your costume like so then
you go to our facebook page facebook.com
slash team Coco and print out one of
these four beautiful masks that's right
then all you do is take a picture of
yourself with this mask on on your
costume upload it to the page and you
can be a winner like so I just killed an
eyes my costume I just Conan eyes my
costume this by the way is what I see
when I close my eyes I've been working
here too long anyway go to facebook.com
slash team Coco we are taking entries
from now until Monday November first and
you yes you could win a pair of tickets
to see our show airfare hotel lodging
and a little extra scratch for gum balls
or whatever you want to buy
so yes facebook.com slash team Coco and
happy Halloween
good luck everybody what do you think
dog
[Music]